well CBS News medical contributor dr.
David agus joins us now with the latest
medical developments David good morning
just a few days ago the CDC released new
sets of guidance on reopening places
like workplaces and schools a lot of us
are waiting on bated breath for this
what's your take away good morning
Michelle
you know originally it's reported the
CDC put together a 63 page report that
had details of every step for opening
schools for summer camps for businesses
for restaurants and then this week out
came a report with literally just
headlines and the headlines were
accurate there was just no details of
what to do and I'm worried I'm worried
that many states don't have the public
health experts to give the real
expertise get down and dirty with the
details the details matter with details
we're gonna do things safely and
efficiently and be able to open the
country without significant numbers of
cases and spread of the virus but the
details we're lacking from the CDC
report this week and they will revamp
this as you pointed out earlier as well
this week the FDA asked or as also
caution the public about a popular rapid
results test well what should folks at
home know about the type and the quality
of tests out there right now so they
were warning about the Abbott test and
the Abbott test is a very quick we'll
call isothermal so it's not PCR but it's
a different way to amplify DNA 5 minutes
for positive results 11 minutes for
negative results there was a study from
NYU
which said maybe there's more false
negatives it's not as good this test the
company has said that the NYU did it
wrong and there's some methodology
issues what I do know is that every test
has false negative is not because
necessarily the technology is bad but
it's because there may not be virus in
the nose in the mouth when you put a
swab in you know we do it there because
that's what droplets come out but there
may be elsewhere in the body at a very
low level and so it's in a sense not the
technology's fault but the biology and
so we're never gonna get a test that
will tell us a hundred percent if
there's virus if we're only looking in
those two areas at the present time
Wow well with more states were you
opening for business we seem to be
shifting strategies from that
containment to mitigating risk how can
we be successful with that strategy do
prevention methods change yes is the
answer you know we're taking more risk
right we're accepting the risk because
we've delayed the virus in a significant
fashion by what we've all done across
the country we have two drug regimens
that have been shown to work our medical
infrastructure is ready and we're
educated on social distancing and masks
masks are the key this virus is spread
by droplets if we wear a mask we will
not spread droplets to other so to me it
is just so critical that we all step up
it's not just okay if you wear a mask
but your neighbor has to also when they
go out of doors if we all do it together
we're gonna have a very safe period over
the next several months with few numbers
of cases if we don't I am worried about
what's going to happen in terms of the
number of cases with the virus in the
country and we're all hoping that we can
keep those numbers down dr. David agus
thank you so much